- We move around sites much
like a photographer would
taking pictures from many locations.
But with a photographer,
you have a single frame.
(machine whirring)
By using our technology
now each of those pixels
actually has a 3-D location,
x,y,z coordinates.
And we have now brought
that photograph to life
in three dimensions.
(upbeat music)
My name is Scott Lee,
and I'm the Director of
Operations for CyArk.
We have to move the
scanner all around the site
in order to capture every nook and cranny.
CyArk's mission is to
accurately capture, archive,
and share the world's cultural heritage.
What makes the data really unique
is you can see we can look
at it from every angle.
So, we can just pop
literally go through a window
and let's check out the
interior of the chapel.
We're documenting the physical evidence
of the people came before us and
we're documenting for the
people that come after us.
Sites in general face
numerous threats today
whether it's environmental
or the intentional
destruction of heritage,
especially in the Middle East.
These sites are being destroyed
faster than they can be physically preserved.
Part of this initiative is
to digitally document them,
so we have a record for humanity
and possible reconstruction in the future.
CyArk has done over 200
projects on all seven continents
from Mt. Rushmore, in the United States,
to Chichen Itza in Mexico,
to the Tower of London in Europe.
Even the Sydney Opera House in Australia.
And as we move around these sites,
we capture billions
and billions of points.
And we collect, you know, tons of data.
(intense music)
This is the data set we
captured in Mexico City.
This is Templo Mayor.
What makes this site really unique is
it was recently discovered
actually in the '70s,
which for archeology is very recent.
If you can't come to
Templo Mayor in Mexico City,
well, pop on your computer and
you can virtually access this.
We are walking on the
archeology; it’s very fragile.
You need to be careful where you step,
where you put your machines,
how you document.
Documenting these sites and storing them
for future generations
is an important endeavor.
I come to work everyday knowing I'm
doing something good for humanity.
Because without knowing our past,
we won't know our future.